hey everybody it's Mike from motor flows
and welcome to today's video you know
today is Friday the 13th 2023 and you
know it's an interesting day you know in
the S PS we were coming in the session
and we're trading a bit lower right if
you remember uh the day before Thursday
right the CPI number came out and you
know we were just all over the place
like uh looks like one of those EKGs and
then we opened up pushed a little bit
higher sold off then we were selling off
coming into the cash session and
actually we made a new low before the
cash opened up
um but we didn't take out that low then
we rallied uh pretty much the rest of
the day and you know we closed up at
4019 so it was a big move from basically
around 60
um what was that 62
all the way up to 19
um so quite a nice move now
yesterday I was talking about value
finding value in the market now most of
us have heard of you know value areas
things like that right and a lot of
Traders will like to do a value area you
know they'll show the value they'll draw
a profile and it'll cover the whole
entire day or you know they'll even you
know put up yesterday's profile this is
a tool that I got from Ninja caters
um you know it's just a simple tool to
draw out the value areas and people say
well you can see you know take off this
other profile nah let's keep it on
so this one take off today's so this was
yesterday's
volume profile right and let's say well
I see your point of control you know we
were sort of rotating around there the
problem I've always had with volume
profile and again you know I studied
Market profile back in the 90s from Dan
Graham's at the CME he's a very famous
teacher there
um user of volume profile
and
I I just thought that you know for me my
own style of trading you know intraday
in and out if I'm looking at say the
profile you know how we're trading
relative to yesterday or you know even
today so for example right let's start
that
um you know this is you know we're
coming in here 8 30 in the morning okay
so this is today's profile so this is
yesterday's profile this is today's
profile cash is opening up right in here
um we rally up to the value area high on
the volume profile for today now again
yesterday's point of control is over
here at two and three quarters I mean
you can make the argument now you know
we draw that line there put it there you
know the market came all the way up it
got up to O2 and it came off down to 94.
wow okay that's great but you're not
getting many trading opportunities per
se because you know if you're looking
for you know a test of yesterday's value
area high or value area low or point of
control or even today's it's really only
giving you just a handful of
opportunities now this day today right
we sold off and we rallied all the way
back up and you know with with order
flow
I took the idea of looking at the volume
profile and I wanted to put it on a
shorter time frame I actually put it on
a bar by bar basis now what I'm not
looking at the shape you know because I
know a lot of Traders are all caught up
in looking at the shapes and how
profiles are forming you know you know
is it a p shape is it a b shape
Etc things like that but really I'm just
concerned with the value area high the
value area low where the point of
control is falling in there right and
and how we're trading relative to it or
you know as people that look on a more
macro sense how is trading relative to
yesterday's value or even a weekly value
so what we did right is we said hey
let's put it on the bar right because
this is just your normal volume
footprint chart the bid ask which has
been around for decades already now and
we said hey let's draw where the value
area is on the bar because
I want to know where the value area high
is where the value area low is we
already know that was one of the key
components of order flow is the point of
control right that's each bar has a
point of control that's the price level
in the bar where the most volume trades
okay well if you're looking at that why
not also look at the value area high the
value area low I mean we could have just
drawn a line to indicate value area high
value or low but the nice thing about
order flows is kind of visual and you
could plot it on the bar and sort of you
know where it's forming and it's
interesting because you know we're all
so used to looking at normal
candlesticks but when you're looking at
the value of a bar it's quite
interesting you know sometimes it forms
you know on one side of the bar or
um you know in the Middle where it's
expected or where you're seeing
um you know like like this candle here
right we're trading you know we open up
trade all the way down and we close up
but we we didn't even close within value
right and if you've ever studied volume
profile Market profile you know it's
important where you're closing relative
to the value area for the day or where
you're opening up relative to the
previous value areas now one of the
things that I like to look for
and I was showing it to people on a 30
second chart yesterday and I did get a
couple emails and comments saying Mike
you know 30 second chart that's too fast
for me you know I don't know who's going
to look at a 30 second chart okay fine
let's extend it out a one minute chart
okay same things I'm looking for right
I'm looking for those point of controls
or sorry the value areas where they
don't get retested in the next bar and
it's potentially can start running right
because you know that you know the these
in profile
analysis whether it's Market profile
volume profile you have the phrase
virgin point of control the naked point
of control right it's a sign of poor
structure the market is going to come
back to eventually it may it may not now
what I've noticed on you know on a more
micro level meaning you know a one
minute chart or something like that is
sometimes it might never come back to
those areas
um for a long time okay especially on a
daytime because we're day Traders right
and so we're not looking to take a a
virgin point of control like here and
expect the market to come back three
days from now to that level by that
point I'm over this level I'm focusing
on new levels so basically what we're
looking for are those
value areas that you know are just being
left out there right dangling here right
here's one okay but again you don't know
that the value area is going to not be
retested until the second bar closes
okay here's another one this one's more
powerful right because now this is your
value area here you got every Bar's got
a value area and you're watching where
the second bar closes is it closing
above it or is it coming back into it
right if it closes above it doesn't test
back into it great that's a potential
trade now what you want to be watching
is the next bar is it continuing in that
direction this next bar no comes back in
there that's not a valid trade here's
another example okay here's your value
area
then the next Bar opens up and starts
running runs to the upside okay it
doesn't come back in and test it okay
good now let's watch the next bar okay
starts trading up okay it doesn't come
back down perfect right this is my
opportunity to be getting long in this
bar then it starts going up right keeps
going up and this is from
you know what bars you know 78 79 in
here trades all the way up into up you
know 10 points Within
10 12 minutes okay
here was a potential short right after
you got long you had a potential short
okay we're trading below it but then the
next bar
trades right back up into it so that
short opportunity well you should you're
already long so you're not really
concerned that you got to cover it or
take your loss
and you could write it up right it was
the same thing that I'm looking for
right here later in the day right
whether it was a 30 second chart a one
minute chart so this is at nine in the
morning okay point of control I'm sorry
value area next Bar opens up okay then
the next part trades into it not really
a trade opportunity here we go open up
uh sorry the value areas
there it's exposed next bar doesn't
trade back into it next Bar opens up
okay fine that's your area to be getting
long okay then you get a little short
here
it comes back up in here tests it to get
another long here another short here
okay but you can see what's interesting
about this is
these are acting as support and
resistance I mean if you're looking at
this just take it from right here okay
this is the value area okay it comes
back in here it's holding that support
goes up you have this new value area
here it comes back down to that evaluary
and it's holding you have a bearish one
here acting as resistance so what does
it do it comes right back up there
bullish one here okay and you see it's
just holding in here bearish bearish
it's just holding there as well okay
this is a doji one that's why it's gray
here's another one supportive goes up
goes right back down what's it do it
goes sideways at that support area kicks
off another support area
okay and you can just see how it happens
like this all day long right your
support area comes right about tests it
goes back up
okay
this is a do gray area then here support
is just going sideways and again you can
see this day in and day out here's your
value area right goes up starts going up
turns into resistance here okay support
resistance resistance starts coming down
testing these support areas
all right and then obviously later
started shooting up right on that big
run up to these new highs the resistance
area here
right another resistance area support
support
right it keeps going up and this on a
one minute chart same thing if you're
looking at a five minute chart right I'd
be looking for the same things now on a
five minute you may not get as many
signals as you would on the 30 second or
a
um
one minute chart
but you know here 11 45
okay right here 11 45.
it's up it's holding
okay then it runs into some resistance
here comes back down to that support
area then it starts working its way back
up
you got a new support area okay just
like that I mean it's
something that I I've been using for a
year for let's say years we've added
this onto our software
in 12 yearly 2023 late
2021 I think it was second half of 2021
and I just found it very useful to use
in my trading you know before I would be
drawing out little profiles I like to do
you know sort of anchored profiles like
you know from a high to a low and see if
there's anything interesting going on
right so from like this swing high after
the cash open to this low see if
anything's interesting going on in here
if we're testing or coming back up if
we're going to run into some resistance
things like that
um you know that I would draw from this
swing low you know once we make this new
swing High when we do we come down into
the point of control and honestly I
found that to be a bit tedious I'm like
I need something a little bit better and
I just found putting it in the actual
profile is much more useful right I mean
and every Market you know whether it's s
PS or gold right this is my gold chart
you know you could see the gold here
okay let me uh get the crosshairs up all
right here this value area here another
value area here
another value smaller one here this is a
stacked imbalance
then you're sort of running up in here
the high of the day some potential short
here potential short but again it's not
going any further down than that one bar
and people say well you got a bullish
one here Market didn't go anywhere well
okay we're at the highs of the day 1920
uh five basically after we had been
rallying since
you know going way down here you know
740 there was a nice
point of control you could have gotten
long off of right at 19 bucks
so again you know whether it's gold
whether it's
e-minis you know I don't know
I guess you can even look at currencies
right pull up Euro currency I'd be
looking for the same thing now again now
this is a
five minute chart
this may take a minute or two to come up
because I don't have the five minute
chart loaded one of the things I've
noticed with ninjatraders if you
actually have like that chart that
you're trying to pull up again it will
load a bit faster but you can see here
right you can see the levels right here
right here
and again you know once you start adding
a little bit of common sense to it like
oh okay I've got a swing low coming in
here and I got that bullish value area
okay you know maybe I could be looking
to get long
right if you're at near a low or up here
near uh near a high you know come up
here going sideways and you left with
that big value area there before the
market starts dropping again there's so
many ways you could use it rather than
just
indiscriminately taking every value area
that's just out there like this was
yesterday okay we're up here this is a
high of the day at 1205 this is a five
minute chart then you go sideways and
then you get that bearish value area
here and the next bar another one
all right and then we even come back and
test it before we sell off
so I mean there's plenty of
opportunities and you can see here right
we hit a support area
and we're holding that support
so there's trust me there's a lot of
ways you could use this and apply it to
your own trading especially if you've
got some sort of indicators and where it
gets much more interesting is when you
add other tools to it
um you know such as if I were to add say
the exhaustion prints okay let's just
pull that up here really quick
exhaustion Prince where are you and
again it's your currency and we'll keep
it at nine but I could even just
put it in at five okay and I'll just
make it
well I'll draw it on until tested this
will be interesting I'll make a little
bit darker so it's a little easier to
see because it's both green and red as
well but by having it slightly darker it
can stand out a bit more
and again you know this is the beauty of
order flow because there's a lot of
little things that you could take away
and use into your trading so look at
this
okay what do we got here
this bar here with the naked value area
it's got an exhaustion print
down here
naked value area it's got an exhaustion
print you can almost just look for
things like that so hopefully you know
you're starting to think about you know
how you could use it in your own trading
and especially if you have my software
you know how flexible it is with adding
certain things of order flow so
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you'll be notified when I
post a new video and you know be sure to
like it as well you know those likes uh
do add up over time and
struck my ego so thanks everyone have a
great day bye